brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available on consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29 hey
guys my name is Jess it is a 15th of
November and do excuse my voice i am
quite sick but i do want to thank all of
you who donated and change into our
extra life live stream it was an awesome
72 hours and you can still go donate at
tinyurl.com /g SS your life if you feel
so inclined for now let's get to the
news first up the legend of zelda breath
of the wild may not be out in time for
the release of Nintendo's switch
according to a new report blogger Emily
Rodgers who's been proven correct on
Nintendo switch room with in the past
first revealed the news from multiple
sources while Eurogamer corroborated the
information saying they had also heard
the new Nintendo title will not be out
when the switch releases the report
claims that localization for breath of
the wild is more work than anyone had
anticipated Rodgers added that her
sources revealed that localization may
not be finished until the end of
December after which the game will
require between four to six months of
testing at least this would put the
release date for breath of the wild at
around mid-2017 Nintendo's most recent
estimate for the release of the game was
simply 2017 while the switch has been
confirmed for release in March of 2017
next up watch dogs is out on consoles
but it's seamless multiplayer has been
deactivated due to technical issues
Ubisoft published a statement saying
they decided to take down the seamless
multiplayer wherein players can appear
in your game and you in theirs as it was
causing the game to lag and crash
periodically Ubisoft added in order to
eliminate that issue at launch and for
players to enjoy a smooth gameplay
experience we've decided to wait to
launch the scene with multiplayer
feature so it would not impact the core
gameplay experience additionally co-op
is still fully functional by inviting
friends through the game menu however
the bounty hunter mode and other
activities that would occur with other
outside players who enter your game will
be unavailable until the issue is
resolved finally a new battlefield one
update is out now and here's the things
that are changing battlefield ones fall
update boosts the number of
tickets the attacking side in the
operations mode as it was filmed they
lose too often and it's now easier to
capture sections as an attacker given
the time to capture flag has been
reduced the update has also added two
more flag to the suez map in conquest
mode so one teams not able to capture
and lock down all flags as easily as
before dice have also reduced the size
of capture areas in the village to make
it easier to capture flags and even out
the flight the patch also now lets you
customize your soldier from within the
UI provides rent a server support and
makes a series of changes to weapon
balancing gadgets and vehicles you can
check out the massive full list of
changes in our story on gamespot that's
everything I got for you today through
head two games but for our watchdogs to
review in progress let me know what
mattered to you and I will see you again
soon